بدأ الناس منذ اليوم الأول
لسبب
ما يفعله البعض للتعبير عن الهوية ،
والبعض يفعل ذلك لمجرد أنه أمر رائع وهو
في رأيي صحيح تمامًا ، حيث يستخدمه بعض الأشخاص
كتذكارات والبعض الآخر يحصل على
وشم لعلاج الذكريات المؤلمة
تعال هنا  اسمي براين فين ،
كنت أرسم وشمًا لمدة 20 عامًا هنا في
توليدو أوهايو ، طلبت أليكسا من دلتا ملء
كرة الكلب ، وأعتقد أن أكثر ما يعجبني في
الوشم وما جذبني إليه هو
الحرية في عام 2015 ، قررت أنني
سأذهب  تعال في أحد أيام إجازتي وقم
بالوشم على الندوب التي سببها
الاتجار بالبشر وإيذاء النفس والعنف المنزلي
، لن أكون ما أنا عليه اليوم
دون ماضي ، بدأت في القطع عندما
كان عمري 17 عامًا وشعرت أن هذا هو السبيل الوحيد
أن أشعر بالأشياء في بعض الأحيان عندما كنت قد
خدرت نفسي لدرجة أنني
لم أشعر بأي شيء أصبح
سيئًا حقًا في أوائل العشرينات من عمري ، وذلك عندما تكون
معظم هذه الندوب من ذلك ،
وأعتقد أنني أساعد الناس اليوم  من خلال
الانتهاء من هذا الفصل  في حياتهم
يمكنهم الانتقال إلى المرحلة التالية ، ليس لدينا
تذكير يومي طلبت أليكسا من
دلتا ملء كوب واحد
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنني وصلت حقًا إلى مكان
في حياتي حيث أتجاوز تلك
أشعر بالراحة حقًا مع ما أنا عليه وأنا مرتاح في بشرتي
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن وجود اليعسوب على
ساعدي سيساعدني في تذكيرني بأنني
بنيت هذا المستقبل لنفسي وقد
تحولت وأدرك من  من
المفترض أن أكون وأعتقد أنه
سيساعد من خلال تغطية الندوب لتجنب
هذا الشعور قليلاً
بالرغبة في الألم مرة أخرى ، يتعلق الأمر
ببناء المزيد من الذكريات الإيجابية
وبناء حياة تستحق أن يعيشها اليعسوب
يرمز إلى التحول
وإدراك الذات  أنا أبني على
الماضي وأبني حياة جديدة
لنفسي وأتحول ، ويمكن لشيء جميل
أن ينمو من الألم
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنني اخترت تخصيص الوقت
لمساعدة الناس لأن الكثير من الناس
لا يفعلون ذلك  خذ الوقت الكافي لمساعدة الناس  ر
حتى أي شخص يبحث عن وشم
لأي سبب من الأسباب سأكون هنا
أنت